los colaboradores de alexina Están
preocupados el líder opositor está
aislado en la cárcel está enfermo y
lleva semanas perdiendo peso hasta 8
kilos en las últimas tres semanas desde
su entorno llegan mensajes preocupantes
porque creen que podría estar siendo
víctima de algún nuevo tipo de
envenenamiento esta vez un
envenenamiento lento distinto del que
sufrió en el año 2020 y que casi Le
cuesta la vida al parecer navany en los
últimos días se ha quejado de fuertes
dolores en el estómago desde la cárcel
donde está recluida unos 250 kilómetros
de Moscú aseguran que no le están
maltratando pero el hecho es que el
viernes pasado hubo que llamar a una
ambulancia para que el líder opositor
fuese atendido desde el entorno de
alexina además que el líder opositor no
tienen estos momentos acceso ni a la
comida que le están enviando ni a los
medicamentos aquí Así que sólo depende
de lo que ahora mismo le están
suministrando en la prisión